the situation in East Jerusalem is now
extremely tense Israeli police say
they're on their highest state of alert
after fresh violence they say the latest
shooting in silwan in East Jerusalem
filmed in this video was carried out by
a 13 year old boy using a pistol he's
believed to have targeted two settlers a
father and son both were wounded the 22
year old son is said to be in a serious
condition
the 13 year old boy was also shot and
was questioned by police in the
ambulance on the way to hospital
it follows an attack on Friday near a
synagogue in the settlement of Nevada
also in East Jerusalem where seven
people were shot dead
a guy stopped here to help got out of
his car and got a bullet to the head and
died next to me his son got a bullet in
the back I tried to compose myself I saw
him right here with the gun in his hand
I saw the whites of his eyes I looked
down and went back in the house and got
a bullet in the window
police say the attacker haierial come
age 21 was shot dead in his car as he
tried to escape from the scene
he lived in the Mount of Olives his
parents and neighbors who came to his
house were arrested 42 people in total
were detained
we're here after one of the hardest
attacks in recent years I couldn't win
the situation assessment with all the
security forces we decided on several
immediate actions we have to work with
determination and composure I call on
people not to take the law into their
own hands for that we have an army
police and security forces
on Thursday Israeli forces went deep
into the Janine refugee camp the
deadliest raid since the UN started
keeping records nearly two decades ago
in one day ten Palestinians including an
elderly woman were killed
prime minister Netanyahu now says
there'll be further action what form it
will take will probably be decided by
his security cabinet which will meet
later in Tel Aviv
huh
near the home of the 13 year old boy
that Israeli authorities say was
responsible for the latest shooting
there's been confrontation stones have
been thrown and the Israeli forces have
responded with stun grenades and tear
gas things here feel as though they're
balanced on a knife edge earlier on we
watched two young Palestinians who were
briefly detained by Israeli police and
then subjected to a heavy-handed search
we saw one of them being beaten but the
officers tried to stop us filming and a
settler then berated and pushed our
cameraman James Bay's Al Jazeera
occupied East Jerusalem